hello folks and welcome to rational
science
today we're going to be talking about
this gentleman his name is peter white
and he's an expert in twister theory
and i mean he's an expert i mean if
you're going to try to find out
something about twisters and
especially the math that's behind it
he's the man to see
and he's amanda here okay and so let's
look at a little bit of his bio
okay here uh he's a mathematical
physicist
uh he's been at columbia university for
about 30 years now
and he's a phd in particle theory in
particle theory from princeton
that's where he got his phd his
interests his
latest interest or his main interest is
relationship between mathematics
and qft quantum field theory and his
current project is trying to unify
not string theory but space-time with
twister theory okay so we're going to
learn a little bit about twister theory
today
okay uh he hasn't won many medals uh he
doesn't have too many of them pinned on
his
uh lapel uh but um
and i don't know maybe he has i just
haven't found any
uh but that doesn't take away from him
believe me if uh if a person
is an expert in their own field it
doesn't matter
matter how many medals he's won over his
lifetime maybe they missed them
when they gave out the medals he does uh
carry a blog
not even wrong and that's a famous
phrase
and he's re using it to uh belittle uh
string theory specifically he goes
against string theory he says
it's not even physics so it's not even
wrong
okay and we talked a little bit about uh
strength theory the other day
okay so um what is this string theory
uh in order to answer that question we
have to go
to uh mr white's mentor
and this man is roger penrose he won a
nobel prize this year in
mathematical physics something very
important uh
for mathematicians apparently and not
not important in physics at all
we don't have beauty contests in uh in
physics
uh we don't win any gold medals like
they do at the olympics
we don't give any medals gold medals for
knowledge
okay especially when people don't know
okay they can't explain gravity they
can't explain light they can't explain
anything out there
magnetism electricity but they get
metals makes you kind of wonder
so no we don't worry too much about
metals
but yeah this uh fellow his name is
roger penrose and he did
uh win medals and uh this is him
i think some of you have heard of him
more or less okay
and uh mr penrose is famous for bending
or discovering or inventing i guess uh
the tri-bar
and uh also known as a penrose triangle
and
uh also the staircase he also did some
work with
stephen hawking on the
um singularities on black holes
he's uh wrote a paper on whether uh
single dairies
are naked or not whether they cover
their shame okay
but uh the subject concerns us today he
also started that one
uh is this twister theory okay it looks
something like that
okay and we'll find out what that's all
about
or try it today to figure it out yeah
um
[Music]
well this is where mr penrose starts his
presentation
his presentation on twisters he starts
uh
saying that the following he says
usually we think of space time where
space is three dimensions and time is
another one
okay you've got this space time which is
four dimensional structure
and the basic thing is that it is made
of these
little points we call events okay no
dimension in space
no dimension in time but you see it like
that
those are the points in space-time
events
i don't know about that you know i mean
when you when you go and see
stephen hawking which uh he died a
couple years ago
he says something else about events he
says the following he says an event is
something that happens
at a particular point in space and at a
particular time
so one can specify by four
numbers four coordinates and so the
question is you know an event is
something that happens
then an event is not a point like you
see there is that what a point is is
that what uh
mr penrose is referring to is he
referring to a dot
is that the one he's going to be using
he's saying that
this space time thingy whatever it is
it's made of points
what is a point well a point is a
something that happens
well something that happens does not
happen happen at a location
because happens requires at least two
frames of the universal movie
so you can't talk about location in
terms of something that has
motion motion and location cannot be
reconciled
one is a static concept the other one is
a dynamic concept
he also uh seems to have problems with
dimensions
he's really talking about number lines
you know number nine is not a dimension
a coordinate or a vector not a physics
if he's going to talk about number lines
and keep it within math no problem he
can call him whatever he wants over
there
but once he crosses the line into
physics
uh he's going to use the dimensions
coordinates and vectors of physics not
the ones of
mathematics okay what he's talking about
is number lines
and number lines are not dimensions
coordinates or vectors
and he's probably thinking about that
little um space-time diagram you see
there the
uh the famous fishnet of relativity
okay so uh you know again he starts out
on the wrong foot to try and explain to
us uh this thing he calls space time
that is made of space and time which is
made of
events those are all concepts we don't
make things in physics with concepts
hopefully all objects uh hopefully
physics are done with objects and all
objects are have some image that you can
see
you know uh that it has shape okay
okay uh mr uh penrose continues
okay he continues and he says the
following he says in twister theory
that's not the basic structure
space-time right the basic thing is
something like a photon
okay let's find out what this photon
thingy is
it goes along at the speed of light and
you can identify the points because you
have a family of them going through that
point
okay photons can spin left-handed
or right-handed and you can describe the
wave function of a left-handed one or a
right-handed one
okay usually you add them together
because they're spins combined to give
you the linear polarization
that's the way photons work
photons can spin well let's find out
let's let's look up this word photon
let's see what a photon
is maybe maybe i've got it wrong let's
find out photon is
a type of elementary particle
massless made of energy
its dimensionless lacks spatial
extension
lacks internal structure does not take
up space
well it seems like they're describing
absolutely nothing which is what you see
on the bottom this is a photon
according to mathematical physics so how
can it have spin
uh meaning some kind of angular momentum
how can it have
motion if it's a nothing so far they
described nothing has no mass no size
no volume no radius no diameter
what is this we're talking about nothing
in fact if it's made out of energy
and energy is a concept we don't know of
any object that is made out of concepts
so we have a little bit of problem
already from the start uh mr penrose
does not seem to know
what a dimension in physics is he
confuses it with the number lines of
mathematics
and he also seems to confuse uh a photon
for a thing
for an object you know in physically you
have to have an object
otherwise you're putting a spirit in
there if you put a concept you can't say
that
you transferred information not in
science
maybe in religion you can do that you
can say you can transfer to spirit you
transfer the soul
you transfer conscience you can transfer
all kinds of concepts in religion
in physics you must have an object that
can do the motion
only objects move okay motion
two locations two or more locations of
an object you have to have an object
before you have motion okay so uh he's
moving
a nothing he's moving a photon which is
apparently made out of energy but that's
irrelevant aside from the fact that it's
a concept
uh he's moving that which has no size no
no shape no no anything no mass
what is he moving what are we talking
about and so uh so far we started on the
wrong foot no dimension no object okay
let's continue let's see where where
this leads
okay here mr uh penrose continues he
says
in twister's theory you have two
different formulae
one which works for the right-handed one
and one which works for the left-handed
one just like the
uh photon for the gravitons the particle
of gravity
you want to make it fit in with
einstein's theory so it
changes space space time is changed
by the gravity okay so remember uh space
time you
warp the canvas uh you have to put
something on the canvas warp it
downwards you create the depression
and that becomes gravity so you create
gravity with gravity you create the
depression by putting something in there
in this case a bowling ball known as
what a graviton
okay and you curve space time now
anything that's
clear close to that will fall inside the
hole that's that's the notion that these
people have
okay you find you can do it for the
left-handed ones but
not for the right-handed ones okay you
can do it for left-handed gravitons but
not for
uh right-handed gravitons okay left and
right are not quite the same in the
theory
you can do the left-handed ones but not
the right-handed ones
you're trying to get the right-handed
ones in the framework
which does the left-handed ones okay so
this is
this is their what they're trying to do
mathematically
okay let's keep that in mind so
so far we're talking about no object we
still don't know what a graviton is but
uh maybe maybe we'll find out soon but
the question is
there's an issue there with
left-handedness and right-handedness
apparently electrons can do it but
uh and photons probably do it but
gravitons cannot okay let's continue
let's see what what else uh
mr penrose has to offer here and yeah he
said this is a way of describing physics
this this which is unusual
yeah i bet it is unusual i mean uh you
know
so far we have nothing uh we have no
we have a confusion between the
dimensions of physics and the number
lines of mathematics
so that we started on the wrong foot but
now he's saying that this is a way
an unusual way of describing physics i
agree
if you can spin both of them left and
right like that you can do
also the particle interactions the
strong interactions the weak interaction
you can put the right and the left
together okay uh so there we have a
particle interaction it's uh
using a finemen diagram we have a space
time you know space versus time
they usually uh put all three so-called
dimensions
as they call them number lines on the
bottom on the on the horizontal axis
and they put the number line known as
time something that belongs exclusively
to math has nothing to do with physics
whatsoever
we don't have any use for time we only
deal with objects in physics
and they have time running instead of
height
so it's a weird uh way of doing physics
no doubt about it they have uh
i guess on the horizontal axis we have
width versus
time what sense does it make time
doesn't have direction
but here they put it as a direction
right so again they're talking about
number lines not about
physics not about dimensions not about
coordinates not about vectors we're
talking about number lines okay let's
keep that in mind
if you can spin both of them left and
right like that you can do also the
particle interactions
what particle interactions here we have
a particle interaction
we have an electron moving upwards here
right
and it throws a photon at another
electron pushes it away
great no problem we're going to
understand push the problem quantum
mechanics has is
explaining pull how do you explain pull
with this finding diagram
how do you attract i mean if if two
rocks throw gravitons at each
other right that's what we want to
understand the mechanism
if they throw gravitons at each other
right cast
gravitons how do you pull with those
gravitons there you have a particle
interaction
particle hits particle okay so where's
the attraction how do you pull with that
this is a big problem that these people
have they can't explain the force of
pull
and in fact uh he talks about the strong
force here's the strong force the gluons
okay
and um you can see that the gluon is uh
it's illustrated as a spring as a bed
spring
okay so yeah we can all understand how
uh two rocks can attract each other if
there's a bed spring between them
we can all understand pull but when you
look at the standard model you don't
find bed springs
all you find is little balls you find
glue on balls not glue on bed springs
and what they do is they say look uh the
glue on the glue on spread apart and
they create
these these uh elastic
bonds which i don't know what they are
what other what is that thing that is
stretching bubble gum
i mean what is this where do you find
this this line
is this elongated entity in the standard
model that's the question
okay and you can see uh what they do
they they replace those
things when they talk they replace them
with concepts they say look
the energy required to separate quarks
produces quark antiquark pairs
long before they are far enough to
observe separately
okay so what they're saying is that you
stretch energy whatever energy is
uh mr feinman told us that he didn't
know what energy is
of course because energy is not a what
it's a concept there is no
thing called energy and so they're going
to stretch this non-thing
this concept they're going to stretch uh
love they're going to stretch
i don't know intelligence here and by
doing so they create a cork and what is
a cork i guess a bunch of energy
more energy so again they're doing all
their physical interpretations
with concepts and we don't do physical
interpretations with concepts in gen
in physics because uh you need objects
to explain mechanisms
we're trying to find out what the
mechanism of gravity is remember that
that's what we're trying to do here
and these people are saying that they
can do attraction between quarks between
rocks between whatever but whether it's
the graviton in the case of rocks
whether it's the gluon in the case of
quarks
and and then and they're not explaining
the mechanism they're not saying what
keeps those two quarks together and so
they say well it's energy
and the way they put it is in reverse
they say if you try to pull
two quarks apart all you're doing is
stretching the glue on
and that creates more quarks and what
does it glue on a bunch of energy
great we learned a lot okay yeah they
treat all this stuff mathematically
and so they have no physical
interpretation for what they're doing
and that's why they have to invent these
uh
explanations these theories if you can
call them that okay
physical interpretations okay uh
mr penrose continues and he says
it has the sort of features which appeal
to me very much
okay one of them is the use of complex
numbers oh hey what is a complex number
let's find out how complicated this
is which includes imaginary numbers
and that's the imaginary numbers which
is the square root of minus one
it's known as an irrational number so
they do what they do they multiply
everything by a rational number an
imaginary number and now they continue
doing math okay
that's what they're going to use uh in
fact he states that
with for quantum it says once you put
that into it you have a whole different
way of looking at the world
no kidding the thing about it is that
quantum mechanics already looks at the
world that way
so quantum mechanics can't do without
its
square root of minus ones okay the
states
in quantum mechanics already involve
these complex numbers meaning
irrational numbers so the idea is that
you bring that kind of complex number
geometry into the real world
you're going to bring all this abstract
stuff and you're going to say it's part
of a real world okay
and somehow the quantum and classical
worlds will get a bit
mixed up yeah there's very
beautiful mathematics in the complex
world which you don't see in the real
world
well we're talking about the real world
or we talk about an imaginary complex
inexistent world i mean the real world
is the existing world what are you
talking about
i thought we were going to do physics
here i thought we were going to explain
um what is it gravity
so let's find out yeah sorry you got the
wrong winner
he says the following he said how he got
into this into this math
thing okay he says and that's what
twister theory does
it gives you a complex number real and
imaginary together
your imaginary meaning also irrational
that's also what it's called
uh includes that a picture of the world
which involves quantum ideas as well as
classical ones
okay so they're trying to classical
means you're going to try to
imagine the theory and that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
imagine the theory okay they're they're
they have a mathematical description
they're going to give a physical
interpretation
and what they're saying is that this
playing around with the equations by
introducing
imaginary numbers and irrational numbers
really complex numbers
what it'll allow them to do is really
make sense
of quantum mechanics that's what they're
trying to do okay and they're going to
apply it to gravitons
of course when i was uh a mathematics
undergraduate i was absolutely stunned
by the magic that there is in these
complex numbers
okay so you were wild by mathematics
great uh 1 plus one equals two
it's a tautology so uh these this is
what
mesmerizes them you know hypnotizes them
uh wouldn't it be nice if
somehow that was what governed the world
uh yeah i mean
uh idealism maybe a little bit too much
okay uh this is what mr white
uh does with this he does i mean mr wood
is an expert in math no doubt about it
and he's writing two papers uh or i
think you wrote them i don't know if
he's
about to publish them and here they are
you see them real quick here
and what i want you to notice is that in
this paper
uh hyper functions and imaginary time
quantization
uh whatever that is all about you can
see it's
there's no pictures in there there are
no pictures all you see are equations
and you would think that if he's going
to talk about twisters you know
i guess that he's trying to explain
gravity you would at least see one
picture
somewhere in that in that uh in that
paper
never will you see a picture in a uh
published paper
of these people all you'll see is a
bunch of equations and so people out
there 99.99 of the people
out there they don't care about
equations they say okay give me the
bottom line
uh i want to know why this pencil falls
to the earth
okay why it falls to the floor that's
all i want to know
just give it to me straight uh how does
that work
and these people say well you got to
take you know you got to
look at hyper functions to understand it
you got to look at imaginary time
and you're going to learn a lot about
twister theory you know at the
university level phd level to really
really understand it
and so here we have these group of
people there's five of them in the world
and they talk about twister theory
because they are experts in
twister theory and nobody knows what
they're talking about then you have the
other group over here the strength years
they talk about they're strange these
guys don't talk to them the other guys
don't talk to these guys
and so we have the twister
mathematicians and we have the
string mathematicians each one's
developing equations out there and you
just ask them look
i'm just very humble i just want to know
why the pencil fell to the floor
and they tell you that you have to take
a course in math
and you say well holy i just wanted to
know the simple you know i mean here's a
pencil
here's the earth we know that the pencil
is attracted to the center of the earth
what attracts it there all i want to
know what attracts it there
and it seems like all you need to do is
figure out what invisible entity is
coming in contact with the skin
of the pencil that's how simple it is
and these people are saying no no you
need to understand all this man you say
but
you know it's it's counterintuitive that
i would need all this stuff you would
think that it's more intuitive that
all you need is some some identify the
invisible physical
object that's pulling or pushing the
pencil
and the answer they give you is that
well you know father universe doesn't
agree with our um intuition
your intuition is wrong and who says
that their intuition matches
father nature's father universe's
intuition or the way he does things
does this math represent how he does
things and i don't mean by how a
description i mean how
the cause the mechanism i want to know
the mechanism of gravity
and these people are giving me a
description saying well
uh that's important and here's the
explanation the explanation is
warp space or gravitons yeah but you
can't explain it with gravitons and
a warp space where time is a concept
you can't say that you're going to warp
time and that prevents the earth from
flying out of the solar system
and they say again that your intuition
is wrong that father universe doesn't
think like you
and again does father universe think
like him is that what he's suggesting is
what he's implying and here's uh
another paper uh by this gentleman and
uh this
again i guess he's gonna be publishing
it soon or he's about to publish or
whatever
this is a draft version and he's got on
his website uh
blog and uh
what do we see we see equations nowhere
do you see a picture
so it's all like that it's all
non-pictures
and you would think that physics is
about pictures
physics should be you should be able to
explain physics simple physics
like mechanisms to a baby
these people say uh well here's the
explanation
but all the explanations are irrational
they either have they're either bending
concepts
warping time or they're throwing
particles at you and saying i attract
you with that i throw tennis balls at
you but you come closer to me
so all the explanations are irrational
you can't make sense of
any of them and so what are we supposed
to do
we don't have communication because
these people are doing a lot of math
there
and the question is is that math
relevant is that worth anything
has this man spent his whole life uh
in a worthless pursuit by doing all this
math what is all this math worth
if they cannot explain a simple thing as
how a pencil falls to the floor
this is what you got to think about okay
these people make a lot of money by the
way you're paying for their salary so
the question is whether you really want
to pay for his salary
for him to do what equations publish
papers in which
he gives a lot of equations and
he doesn't give you a mechanism a
rational mechanism
and all we need to do for a rational
mechanism
is to identify the invisible objects and
hopefully there are
objects out there invisible intangible
objects that mother nature uses to do
gravity and light because otherwise
you're putting spirits
in that same space and you're doing
religion
so you can't come with an equation and
substitute it for
a physical interpretation for a
mechanism
for a cause okay
okay um so what does mr
white do well uh he does particles
that's what he does
and this is what he's been educated to
do he's been trained
educated to deal with particles uh they
call them waves sometimes because the
particles are the ones that wave so
waves also include particles
except when you're waving vectors which
is another thing that they wave
so we're replacing this and we're saying
look all atoms in the universe are
physically interconnected
that's what they've been missing all
these 400 years since
robert hook came up with the wave
nature of light because before that it
was all particles 100
particles everybody would do particles
after uh the
17th century uh revolution uh
scientific revolution they
figured out that they could that light
apparently had wave
properties attributes and so since then
they've been doing waves particles
particles waves particles particles
waves
so that's what we've been doing now for
400 years and that's what mr
was trained and educated on and he never
thought
or even imagined questioning that i mean
after 400 years are you going to
question
the particle or the wave
assumptions i mean that's what
everybody's been doing
so it never crossed his mind that he
could question that
and he just kept doing particles and
waves really particles because that's
what quantum is
they use the wave as a crutch when they
can't explain something the slit
experiment or
i don't know um
compton wavelengths or whatever then
they bring in the wave
other or for example um polarization
and otherwise they always do particles
and what is a wave the motion particles
so we're back to particles no matter
what you do you're always back to
particles
but these are magical particles for the
last hundred years they're no longer the
classical particles though the little
ball
now these are magical particles because
they don't represent
the word particle is a misnomer and they
use it very handily to talk about
particles
because it's got that duality that you
could be referring to waves you could be
referring to chord puzzles or maybe to
neither maybe just to some magical
uh value a magnitude
uh an amount which is what they're going
to put in equation
that's what the word particle means to
them so when they accelerate a particle
they're accelerating an amount it could
be
an amount of energy which is again an
amount
not a thing or they're accelerating a
charge
what is a charge it's an amount 1.6
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs that's
what
what it is it's a number that's what
they're accelerating so these people are
always accelerating numbers that's what
they do in their equations
and then they casually extrapolate that
into physics like saying okay let me
give you the physical interpretation
you have this particle that moves at the
speed of light
you see it's a ball no no it's got no
size
no volume no mass so what are you
talking what are you accelerating
what is accelerated at the speed of
light what is the physical object
and some of them will tell you hey it's
the acceleration of nothing it's the
undulation of nothing that's what a
photon is
okay so uh this is what he has in mind
he has
either particles or waves never thought
about questioning any of these two
that's what they've been doing for the
last 400 years and the question is
whether
either of these two meet these criteria
which are
uh the attributes of light uh is it wavy
like in the case of particles there the
flow of photon beads
uh light moves in a manner of
oscillating waves that one
seems to be moving straight not up and
down like you see at the bottom which is
a bunch of vectors okay so we we've got
a little bit of a contradiction already
at the start here because
the particle the flow of particles the
flow of photon beats does not explain
the waviness that
light seems to have the bottom one
explains the waviness but what is waving
vectors so both of them fail
both the particle and the wave the
transverse wave that
mr frenel uh came up with
to explain polarization especially both
of them fail the bottom one is not an
object though the
top one the particles are objects but
you cannot explain oscillating waves
with that
so neither one passes the first criteria
of the attribute of light
uh next one laser ranging if you turn
your laser on one second later you will
detect the light
on the the moon approximately 300 000
kilometers away
in other words it takes one second for
the laser beam to hit that
retro reflector that the astronauts put
on the moon for those of you who are not
flat earthers and believe that humans
went to the moon okay it takes one
second approximately okay
roughly and the question is um
why can't the particles travel faster if
they're going one way why can't the
waves the bottom ones the two transverse
waves travel
faster i mean what what prevents them
from traveling faster
that's the question okay or slower for
that matter right because
they claim that uh these things travel
slower when they go through denser media
but then when you want them to travel
faster they say well they can't travel
faster
uh through vacuum and what is vacuum a
bunch of particles
so here they go through the particles of
vacuum and they can only travel to a
given speed
no more but then when they travel
through other particles the ones that we
have in the real world you could say
uh they go slower that's that's their
explanation they have this thing called
refractive index where they
make a conversion of the speed of light
to according to
how dense a medium is uh constancy of
light they cannot explain that
why frequency is inversely proportional
to wavelength c equals
frequency times wavelength the speed of
light in a vacuum at least
at least they'll agree with that is 300
000 kilometers per second okay
and uh you can increase the frequency
only at the expense of wavelength in
fact uh it is
that difference that gives us the colors
of the spectrum okay
okay um ray reversibility mirrors
reflect and refract light along
what rectilinear trajectories or
straight paths whichever one you want
but that thing is
straight as an arrow okay so ray
reversibility shows that
light travels or extends straight
right light lines along or runs parallel
to a straight axis
amplitude light obviously has it and
then you have faraday and maxwell laws
one
field so-called field magnetic field
induces the electric field
and vice versa how does uh how do
particles explain that
how do they explain these attributes of
light
so particles is a bad start and waves is
a no-brainer either because
you know you can't you can't start with
waves because
you got to identify what the physical
object that is waving waves
is a is a verb there is no physical
standalone object called the wave
okay okay so um
what do we propose instead well here it
is
uh does this one pass the attributes of
light let's see let's find out well it
looks like it does
we're saying that uh what we have here
is a um
two atoms one is two dimensional the
other one three dimensionals just so you
can see
how it's built how it's constructed more
or less okay and they're
connected by a rope they're physically
connected by rope the rope is a physical
entity not not a field field is a
concept there is no physical object you
call the field
but um but uh a rope a rope is a
physical object you don't believe me go
to the
hardware store and ask for a rope and
they'll give you a rope a two-strand
rope
it'll give you something looks more or
less like that that you're seeing there
ask them for a field let's see what they
give you what do they give you a
football field
so there is no physical object called
field but
but rope yeah there is a object called
rope
and it's made out of two strands two
physical strands and that's what
uh we're com we're proposing um
binds any two atoms in the universe so
all atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected
does it pass all these attributes of
light obviously it's uh it's wavy okay a
rope is wavy already structurally wavy
uh it tells you why uh it goes so fast
at 300 000 kilometers per second why
because
uh torsion is the fastest thing
imaginable 3d torsion not a 2d
transverse wave
but a 3d torsion along
a physical medium okay so now we have a
physical interpretation for light
um is it constancy of light yes c equals
frequency times wavelength
the shorter you make the links the more
links you can get for any length of rope
and vice versa okay so c equals
frequency times wavelength is the the uh
equation of a rope not of a transverse
wave
rate reversibility always travels
straight because it's taught it's a part
rope it's
it's stretched to the limit that's also
gives you the reason why
c is a constant everywhere uh little c
is a measure
of the tension on the rope okay
and so the rope is constantly under
tension it's pulled by every atom in the
universe
is pulling on that rope through other
atoms
uh amplitude obviously you can see the
amplitude there and you can see why one
induces the other one into being or why
it misled the uh
mathematicians to believe that one
induces this thing they call field
uh into being and one of the problems
uh with mathematical physics is uh and
that goes
especially to in regards to mr white and
that's that
what these people do is they believe in
experiments
so they go they do an experiment they
can't see
or touch the mediator that mother nature
uses for gravity for life
or magnetism they can't see or touch
that
so they infer it indirectly and for the
last 400 years we've been doing
indirect assumptions based on
experiments
what does that tell us about experiments
that tells us that we don't need
experiments
in physics to determine the invisible
intangible mediators that mother nature
uses or father universe whoever you pray
to
okay you're not going to discover them
through an experiment
the only way to uh
reach an agreement with mother nature or
father universe
is to visualize you have to see you have
to use the mind not the eyes
not the hands you got to use the mind
you got to
see you got to say what could mother
nature be using to do
light what could mother nature be using
to do gravity
and it better be a what better be an it
better be a thing
because otherwise you're putting spirits
in that same space you're using black
magic
and when you use concepts it's even
worse because now not even god can do
that
you know you can't say that you sent
energy or that you have a field between
two objects or that you
have mass how does mass pull on another
mass
does it send mass uh throws mass at it
does it throw energy does it
pull through the field field is a bunch
of numbers
so you can't use concepts as physical
objects to give
a physical interpretation all those
words
you can keep them within math we have no
use for them in physics when you come
across the line into physics
you got to use the language of physics
and that's where all concepts die at
that line
as soon as you cross that line forget
about all your concepts now you got to
give us a physical interpretation we
want to know how gravity works we want
to know how light works what what the
mediator of light is we want to know
uh what the what this thing you call
field is
we want an object on the screen or in
person or whatever maybe you can show us
what a field is
you can bring it to the conference show
us exactly what a field is don't tell me
that you got to feel that this is the
equation we don't care about that
okay okay and here's uh not only do they
fail with light they fill with space
and i don't know what notion uh mr white
has of space but obviously
he's got some notion i mean he's gonna
try to merge
his uh twister theory with space time
right that's his goal
this is space time there you have space
and time a little
uh fishnet canvas trembling whatever
he's gonna bend it with mass i guess
because that's what general relativity
does i mean if he's going to merge both
of them he's going to rely on this model
uh we wonder why the moon doesn't fly
out of the solar system okay so it keeps
going around the earth why does it fly
away what keeps it bound
well the general relativity says there's
a depression caused by the
mass of the earth bending downwards
space-time then they tell you well don't
don't pay attention to that that's
you're not supposed to take it so
literally no no i gotta i gotta explain
why the moon doesn't fly out of the
solar system tell me
what physical entity stands in the way
of the moon flying out is it warped time
is that what you're going to tell me
so again we have a problem because the
physical interpretation is irrational
they're using a concept
called time they're warping it and they
say that's why the moon doesn't fly away
and then when you say well that's
irrational it says you're not supposed
to take the analogy so literally
so they they take away time at the end
when you say well it's a concept yeah
it's a concept but that's how we explain
it so it's an irrational explanation so
there's no makes no sense whatsoever so
don't try to imagine it or even try to
understand it it's
it's you can't understand and that's why
they say well you got to take math to
understand it
yeah because not in physics maybe in
math okay
okay uh so mr voigt uh probably believes
also in this that maybe
space is some kind of ether maybe a
bunch of particles
or like uh what was it uh mr laughlin uh
nobel prize also he says you know uh
the the uh what we use in uh quantum
mechanics and in mathematical physics in
general
is an ether but we don't call it that
because it's taboo
the word is taboo they can't use the
word ether but that's what they're
referring to a bunch of particles
what's the wave it's a waving of
particles
so i don't know what other thing mr
white could be thinking of when he's
thinking about
space it's either that space-time canvas
or maybe a bunch of particles
i have no idea what what he would think
space is
okay and so we ask uh mr white
uh what is space can you tell me what
space is
or define the term or whatever point to
it or whatever
and these are the questions that or the
uh answers you'll find on the internet
maybe
one of those is the one he's referring
to i don't want to put words in his
mouth but
almost surely he's got one of those okay
the boundless three-dimensional
extent what's an extent is it a physical
object or an abstract concept
physical space physical is an object
space is nothing so we have a something
and a nothing
right something nothing that's what he
said phys or someone said that physical
space
is that is that what uh mr wood is going
to present physical space
uh something nothing 3d space a
geometric
setting in which three values are
required to determine the position of an
element point and again we found out a
point where
what is a point is a point a dot or is
it a location
i mean if it's a location don't call it
a point call it a location and if it's a
dot call it a dot a two dimensional dot
or three dimensional ball i don't know
which one they want to use for
location so so you either talk about
location you talk about the object
and what they did they condensed them
into the word point and so the word
point is one of those dualities that
mathematicians like because it means
both things it means
the object dot and the concept location
they love that because they can now
give a pictorial representation within
their presentation
within their dissertation okay in 3d
space well space
is nothing so there is no such thing as
3d space
okay space has no dimensions whatsoever
because it's nothing
objects have uh 3d space
objects have 3d three dimensions
physical dimensions like we
in other words the dimensions of physics
right length width and height
only objects have the space has no
length or height okay space is nothing
vacuum space devoid of matter great
and uh vacuum you look it up and
they'll tell you that vacuum is made out
of particles and here you see some
examples the quantum vacuum
the quantum state with the lowest
possible energy what is energy a concept
there's no such thing as energy so
whatever
energy is it's got very little of it
quantum foam fluctuation of space time
so here you have this concept
and it's fluctuating vibrating i guess
right that's what quantum foam is what
is quantum foam
that's a another version of space direct
see another version of space the vacuum
has an infinite sea of particles with
negative energy
you have positive energy uh when you
feel great and
energy when you're down and out i guess
i mean what is this negative energy
just a mathematical concept and it's and
that's what this vacuum
uh that dirac invented is made out of
and what is it virtual particles
uh particles that combine to form
nothing
and then they separate the form two
particles so we have uh a nothing made
of two particles like i always say you
have a black and a white ball
they form they get together and they
form no ball
and then the no balls separates and
forms a black and white ball
that's what these people are saying so
they have all these vacuums all these
spaces all these nothingness
and all the nothingness are made out of
something all of them there's not one
nothing space vacuuming all of
mathematical physics
that is total nothing no all of it is
something there's no such thing as void
in mathematical physics they have to put
a background because they can't
otherwise explain any of the things that
they do any of the
phenomena they can't explain all the
invis any other invisible phenomena
how do we do it in rational science well
we do it a little different
what we do is we define terms so that we
talk sensibly we can talk consistently
rationally
foundations of physics the first
principle is the golden principle
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object
something uh all these mathematical
physicists have never learned in 400
years
yes you we don't do use math we don't do
experiments what we have
is to define the what an object is for
the purposes of physics
because you can't do physics without an
object what if what physics are you
doing what are you analyzing what are
you measuring
if there's nothing in front of you so
yeah you had better
do have an object before you do physics
and something which is an object right
that which has shape what is nothing
that which doesn't have
shape now we can use these words
consistently rationally scientifically
something is the opposite of nothing
they're antonyms and i gave an example
something is that black stuff you see
there
whatever it is it's got shape and
nothing is the one
next to it which is that which doesn't
have shape see how easy it was all these
years all you have to define is
something in nothing space is nothing
space is that which has no shape which
means particles have no way of escaping
space because space has no boundaries
not because it's infinite but because
it's not an object
infinite is an adjective and in science
we can only apply
adjectives to objects and there is no
object which is
infinite because all objects are finite
we're done
see how easy it was all you have to do
is define the terms so that you can talk
sensibly
and so we have nothing which is space
and we have all this matter all these
atoms are
just floating with respect to each other
in the nothingness we call space which
has no boundaries
therefore space cannot turn into matter
matter cannot turn into space
and there was no beginning to the
universe as
general relativity what mr white
believes in
says okay okay
um just one more issue here a couple
more issues here's uh
mr ward cannot use any of these to
define the word object you cannot use
the criteria these criteria okay you
cannot use
c or touch because that requires two
objects mass requires to obviously you
gotta weigh something to
determine its mass or count the number
of atoms or whatever unit you're gonna
use for a mass fund you gotta count them
you gotta tell me the difference between
an elephant and a chair
okay and you say well the yellow man has
gazillions of
made of gazillions of atoms the other
one is uh just one million atoms okay
fine
so you you gotta tell me what an atom is
you know you gotta count them so
again mass is counting uh motion
volume same thing all of them require
all our dynamic concepts
made of again we don't care what
something is made of it's called uh
meriology we don't say that a table is
what it is made of
no table is what i point to that's a
table what it is made out of it's made
out of atoms just like an elephant is
made out of atom just like a house a
tree a rock they're all made out of
atoms
but i have to distinguish the words so i
got to find out what an elephant is
different than a table if i have the e.t
come to earth i have to
teach them my language and i can't use
and say well it's what it's made out of
that's a gazillion atoms that's one
million atoms that's a billion atoms
no that's not an object that's a table
that's a
a tree that's a rock that's the way we
do it in physics we point to objects
because
what the only property that the
all objects in the universe whether
they're two dimensions or
three-dimensional
have is form shape okay
and yes the words form and shape mean
the same thing in physics not in
ordinary speech and mathematics
mathematics right
what they do in ordinary speech and in
mathematics has nothing to do with
physics in physics
shape and form mean the same thing in
fact uh in spanish
uh we uh we don't have a word for shape
we only use the word form
forma okay so we only have form for
everything so we don't have this
shape-y thingy that people made a
distinction in ordinary speech which
came out of mathematics out of geometry
okay uh temporal see something by parts
we don't do that in
science and uh temporal uh is when you
when you don't look at the table in one
shot you look at it piece by piece
there are no observers in physics we
don't accept
testimony witnesses none of that so uh
we don't care what you saw
okay now in objects is that what has
shaped before we put an observer to see
it piece by piece time by time second by
second
uh no it's not a noun it is a noun only
for physics only that which has shape
qualifies as a noun
the word motion is a noun in ordinary
speech it is not a noun
in physics so the word orbit
is a noun in ordinary speech that's not
a noun
in phys physics orbit is a verb wave is
a verb
field is a verb energy is a verb none of
those
are objects standalone objects
standalone objects you point to
can you point to energy can you point to
some kind of shape known as energy
absolutely not can you point to mass no
you can't you get a count mass
if you're counting atoms or units of
mass or whatever
uh color uh needs a vibration some some
kind of a
motion of light in order to see color
you know frequency versus
wavelength it's not as an object is not
a synonym of exist exist in addition you
need location
so an object with location is a
definition of exist
and it's not 3d because we have 2d
objects and they're known as squares and
triangles and so on so uh no
uh 3d is not
an object that's in ordinary speech not
in physics
okay physics shape it's the universal
property of all objects
and here we go with the last one and
this is
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system it's because all atoms
of the earth are bound to every single
atom of the sun the sun twirls the earth
around
like a bunch of lily puddings would
swirl
gulliver at the end of ropes that's why
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
okay so uh
i don't know if you should contribute to
what is it twister theory
by the way uh these people are dying
breed those who
are pushing for experiments like i
mentioned uh sabine
hassenfelder and um nobel prize winner
uh what's the name sheldon glashau
mr white they're all dying breed of
people because
everybody's moving on to strengthening
leaving them behind
are they doing any better no of course
not as i showed that mr maldasena
a couple weeks ago uh he's not doing any
better he's getting into more
abstraction he can't explain gravity any
more than mr white can't
why because they're all using the wrong
hypothesis they're all starting at the
wrong point
they're starting what with particles and
waves once they abandon that
assumption and they assume that all
atoms are interconnected
then maybe they can make a little bit of
progress why can't we see
or touch the mediator of gravity of
light
of magnetism etc we can't because mother
nature specifically made them
invisible and intangible
and so you won't be able to go to the
lab and figure out what
light gravity or magnetism electricity
any of those are
not not by running an experiment the
experiment for gravity here it is you'll
never need another experiment here we
let go of the pen
okay do it again how many times
repeatable experiment let's do it a
million times okay
there it goes that's the only experiment
you ever need now you know what gravity
is gravity is that something that pulls
the pen down what you got to identify is
the physical object
that came in contact with the skin of
the pen
and we say that all atoms of the pen are
connected to all atoms or every atom
that compresses the earth that also
explains why light why gravity goes
through things
okay why one atom is behind another atom
so yeah we do have an explanation of
physical interpretation for gravity we
have a physical interpretation for light
we have a physical interpretation also
for electricity and magnetism
as i showed the other day and for the
workings of the atom
now uh again people get stuck
on this see touch they say why can't i
see and touch they say
how do these ropes cross each other
because
not all objects uh can see
okay you can see or touch not all
objects have the property of touch
the rope does not have the property we
know as touch as we see the ropes
or ordinary ropes in our ordinary lives
in our ordinary lives you know you can't
have a rope go through another rope like
this for example right they can't
crisscross
each other in mother nature's universe
uh that property is missing from the
rope and from the threads
that make up the rope so the rope does
not have the property of touch
and that's a big can of worms i
explained that in my book why god
doesn't exist
uh there i explain why how how
uh something which is uh a rope
the electromagnetic rope acquires the
properties of touch
and of c you know as you can see it
eventually atoms and upwards